welcome everyone this screencast kicks
off our unit on Advanced behavioral
evaluation of nlu models for this unit
we're going to switch gears a little bit
we've been very focused on architectures
and models we are now going to turn our
attention to the nature of evaluation
how we gather evidence and how we Mark
progress in the field
for this unit we're going to focus on
behavioral evaluations those based in
input output behavior and in the next
unit we're going to try to go one layer
deeper to uncover information about how
models manage those input output
mappings
to kick this off I think it's useful to
reflect a little bit on the varieties of
evaluation that we conduct in the field
and in AI more broadly
for this unit as I said we'll be focused
on behavioral methods we are just
focused on whether or not models produce
the desired output given some inputs and
we don't directly attend to how they
manage to do that mapping
standard evaluations are often called
IID evaluations for independent and
identically distributed the intuition
here is that we have some test examples
that are disjoint from the ones the
system was trained on but we have a kind
of underlying guarantee that the test
examples are very much like those that
were seen in training so this standard
mode gives us a lot of guarantees about
what we can expect at test time but it
is also very friendly to our systems
with exploratory analyzes you might
start to venture outside of that IID
assumption you might know or not know
about what the data or what the training
data were like but the idea is that
you're now going to start to probe to
see whether the model has certain
capabilities via examples that you
construct and they might go outside of
what you would expect from the training
data
that could also be hypothesis driven you
might just ask a question like hey does
my model know about synonyms or does it
know about lexical entailment and you
might construct a data set that probe
specifically for ways of answering that
particular question so you're using a
behavioral evaluation to answer a kind
of more conceptual hypothesis driven
question there
in challenge data sets you might start
to Adventure outside of the friendly
mode in this mode with challenge data
sets you might be posing problems that
you know are going to be difficult given
the nature of the training experiences
of your model you're trying to push the
limits to see where it's going to fall
down essentially
and that could become truly adversarial
in the sense that you might have done a
full study of the train data and the
properties of the model and then
constructed examples where you know the
model is going to fail as a way of
revealing some kind of problematic
Behavior or important weakness
and we could escalate all the way to
what I've called security oriented
behavioral evaluations in this mode you
might be deliberately constructing
examples that you would expect to fall
outside of the normal user interaction
with your model maybe with unfamiliar
characters or character combinations to
see what happens and in particular you
might be looking to see whether with
those very unusual out of distribution
inputs the model does something that is
toxic or problematic or unsafe in some
way
those are all behavioral evaluations we
could contrast those with what I've
called structural evaluations probing
feature attribution and interventions
these are the topic of the next unit and
with structural evaluations what we try
to do is go beyond input output mappings
and really understand the mechanisms at
work behind those behaviors and I think
the ideal for that would be that we
under uncover the causal mechanisms
behind model behaviors those go beyond
behavioral testing and I think
complement behavioral testing really
powerfully
let's reflect a little bit on standard
evaluations in the field I think the
upshot here is that they are extremely
friendly to our systems in ways that
should increasingly worry us as we think
about systems being deployed in The
Wider world
four standard evaluations at step one
you create a data set from a single
process that is the part to emphasize a
single process you could scrape a
website you could reformat a database
you could crowd Source some labels for
some examples and so forth and so on
whatever you do
you run this one process and then in the
next phase you divide the data set into
disjoint train and test sets and you set
the test set aside it's under lock and
key you won't look at it until the very
end
that's really good because that's going
to be our estimate of the capacity of
the system to generalize but notice
you've already been very friendly to
your system because step one offers you
a guarantee that those test examples
will in some sense be very much like
those that you saw in training
then you develop your system on the
train set
only after all development is complete
you evaluate the system based on some
notion of accuracy standardly on the
test set
and then this is crucial you do report
the results as an estimate of the
system's capacity to generalize and at
that point you're communicating with the
wider world and saying you have a
measure of the system's accuracy and you
know people will infer that that means
that's the accuracy that they will
experience if they use the model in free
usage
this is the part that worries me step
one was a single process for creating
the data and we report that as an
estimate of the system's capacity to
generalize even though we know full well
that the world is not a single
homogeneous process we absolutely know
that once the model is deployed it will
encounter examples that are very
different from those that were created
at step one and that is the worrisome
part and that is where so-called
adversarial evaluations come in they
needn't be full-on adversarial but the
idea is to expose some of the fragility
of that standard evaluation mode
at step one in adversarial evaluations
you create a data set by whatever means
you like as usual
you develop and assess the system using
that data set according to whatever
protocols you choose
now the new part you develop a new test
data set of examples that you suspect or
know will be challenging given your
system and the original data set
only after all system development is
complete you evaluate the system based
on accuracy on that new test set
and then you report the results as
providing some kind of estimate of the
system's capacity to generalize as
before this is the new piece this
contrast we have our data set that we
use to create the system especially for
training
but then in step three we have a new
test data set and that plays a crucial
role of now offering us an estimate of
the system's capacity to generalize and
to the extent that we have created some
hard and diverse new test sets in this
way we can probably gain increasing
confidence that we are simulating what
life will be like for the model if it is
deployed
and that's a kind of call for Action to
do this really effectively to really
feel like you can get behind step five
here you should construct these
adversarial or challenge data sets in a
way that covers as much of the spectrum
of user behaviors user goals user inputs
as you will expect to see and that
implies having diverse teams of people
battle testing these models and creating
hard examples and studying the resulting
behavior and in that way with a
concerted effort there you can inch
closer to having a real guarantee for
how the model will behave when it is
deployed
it's a Hallmark of Behavioral testing
that you will never have a full
guarantee but you could approach it and
then as the next unit will show you
might supplement that with some deeper
understanding of how the model works
but in any case I feel like this is the
mode that we should be in when we think
about AI systems in this modern era of
ever widening impact
the history of this is kind of
interesting adversarial testing feels
like a new idea but in fact it stretches
all the way back to at least the Turing
test you might recall that the
fundamental Insight behind the Turing
test is that we'll get a reliable
evaluation when we pit people against
computers where the goal of the computer
is to try to fool the person into
thinking it is a person itself and the
human is trying their level best to
figure out whether that entity is a
human or some kind of AI that is an
inherently adversarial Dynamic that is
centered around linguistic interaction
and so I think like we have to call that
the first or certainly the most
influential adversarial test
sometime later Terry Winograd proposed
developing data sets that involved very
intricate problems that he hoped would
get past simple statistical tricks and
really probe to see whether models truly
understood what the world was like
Hector Levesque in this lovely paper on
our best behavior kind of revived this
idea from Winograd of adversarially
testing models to see whether they truly
understand what language and what the
world is like
the Winograd sentences are really
interesting to reflect on now they are
kind of simple problems that can be
quite revealing about physical reality
and social reality and all the rest
here's a typical Winograd case the
trophy doesn't fit into this brown
suitcase because it's too small what is
too small the human intuition is to say
the suitcase and that's probably because
you can do some kind of mental
simulation of these two objects and then
arrive at an answer to the question the
minimal pair there is the trophy doesn't
fit into the brown suitcase because it's
too large what is too large here the
human answer is the trophy again because
of that kind of mental simulation that
you can do and the idea is that this is
a behavioral test that will help us
understand whether models also have that
kind of deep understanding of our
physical reality
here's a case that Keys more into kind
of social norms and roles that people
play the council refused the
demonstrators a permit because they
feared violence who feared violence the
human answer is the council based on
kind of stereotypical roles for
demonstrators and politicians
versus the council refused the
demonstrators a permit because they
advocated violence who advocated
violence again we default to saying the
demonstrators because of our default
assumptions about the roles that people
will play and the idea is to for a model
to get these responses correct it too
needs to kind of deeply understand
what's happening with these entities and
with the social norms involved
that's the guiding hypothesis again
behavioral testing can never give us
full guarantees that we've probed fully
for the underlying capability that we
cared about but examples like this are
inspiring in terms of getting us closer
to that ideal
Hector Levesque took this further in a
way that I think has proved really
inspiring for the field he says for
example could a crocodile run a
Steeplechase the intent here is clear
the question can be answered by thinking
it through a crocodile has short legs
the hedges in a Steeplechase would be
too tall for the crocodile to jump over
so no a crocodile cannot run a steeple
chase again evoking this idea of doing a
mental simulation about a very
unfamiliar situation and arriving at a
systematic answer to the question
and what Levesque was really after was
what he called foiling cheap tricks can
we find questions where cheap tricks
like this will not be sufficient to
produce the desired Behavior
this unfortunately has no easy answer
the best we can do perhaps is to come up
with a suite of multiple choice
questions carefully and then study the
sorts of computer programs that might be
able to answer them again what I hear in
this early paper back in 2013 is a call
for constructing adversarial data sets
that will reveal much more about the
solutions that our models have found